je m'appelle claire clair qu'elle y est
la candidate du parti vert dans moncton
riverview dire aujourd'hui elle est à la
conquête du campus universitaire en
anglais et en france c'est tellement
important c'est nous sommes un pays
bilingue mais aussi nous sommes la seule
province bilingue et bien sûr cette
circonscription tellement bien
les gens sont tellement à l'aise
inconfortable dans les deux ans et
j'adore ça la circonscription fédérale
compte un peu plus de 90 mille habitants
le tiers se dit francophone presque la
moitié parle la langue y as 30
circonscriptions pays à l'extérieur du
québec où il a plus que 5 % de
francophones et donc où les francophones
peuvent avoir un poids électoral
mais c'est sûr que les francophones en
minimes nés retards sont sous
représentés sous représentés et avec
l'impression de ne pas être entendus par
les décideurs des coupes imposées dans
les services en ontario aux politiciens
hostiles au bilinguisme au nouveau
brunswick en passant par les propos de
denise bombardier qualifié de choquant
et insultant à l'endroit des
francophones en milieu minoritaire
il ya un problème linguistique au pays
et si on est sérieux qu'on veut ce vivre
ensemble et si on veut pas avoir
d'autres crises d'unité nationale dans
ce pays il va falloir qu'on soit sérieux
et appuyer le droit des francophones
d'exister et de vivre dans leur langue
peu importe où les habits alors dans
plusieurs circonscriptions les
francophones tente de s'imposer comme
ici dans le nord de l'ontario sont doit
beaucoup le fait que peu chez scolarisée
en français les échos seconde à nous
verser à des premières phrases aussi on
la doit beaucoup au parti libéral
l'indép et un anglais français français
d'abord de doute c'est d'augmenter la
participation francophone ici dans la
région
les francophones devraient être
respectés évidemment oui mais également
représentée dans tous les
tous les milieux de pouvoir assurer une
présence et veiller à ce que leurs
préoccupations soit entendu surtout au
moment où ottawa se prépare
viser la loi sur les langues officielles
qui vient d'avoir 50 ans est ce qu'on
fait c'est non je pense qu on doit faire
mieux dès que vous avez dit de recruter
des minorités dans chaque domaine elle
sait que ses chances de l'emporter sont
minces et se console en pensant que les
deux meneuses sont acadienne mais dans
les autres circonscriptions francophones
hors québec
il reste encore du chemin à faire ici
daniel thibault radio-canada manquent
pas